Hello everyone and thanks for joining me
today. Um, so as Paco so kindly
introduced, uh, I work at Adobe as a
senior information architect for Adobe's
Experience League, which is the primary
learning gateway and documentation
platform for Adobe products, mainly the
B2B powerhouse tools like Adobe
Experience Manager and Adobe Analytics.
connects the pre-sale to post sale for a
lot of our products and is a sort of a
critical cornerstone or touchstone
within the organization. I'm currently
building a knowledge graph and semantic
system to improve customer journeys in a
multitude of ways. Um, today we're going
to talk about intentional arrangement.
Intentional arrangement is the explicit
or implicit acts of organization by
people or by computational processes
acting as proxies for or as
implementations of human intentionality.
By organizing with intention, we can go
from
digital hellscape and yes this is an AI
generated image
to information nirvana.
A structured and curated information
landscape, a semantic by design and
intentionally organized to make sense to
humans and machines, including
generative artificial intelligence.
Information begins with data. We can all
agree on that. LLMs are an assemblage of
statistical models representing patterns
of language. But having data or having a
lot of data is not enough to solve
business problems. To solve business
problems, data must be structured and
contextualized in order to deliver
results relevant to a domain, a
business, the internet, or the world.
In fact, the mainstreaming of AI has
shined a light, I like to say a black
light because it's uncovering or
surfacing all of these issues within
organizations, quality issues, and the
importance of structured semantic data.
Knowledge management practices are
missing, absent from most organizations
and as a result, LLMs cannot make sense
of unstructured business environments.
However, everyone wants a knowledge
graph because graphs have been proven to
be the answer for wayward AI
implementations.
Guess what? A knowledge graphs is a
knowledge management tool. So knowledge
graphs are knowledge management tools
that require knowledge management
practices to render semantic structured
data for machine and human information
retrieval tasks.
Collison Gnik in the Wall Street
Journal, she's a fabulous columnist,
opinion writer, characterizes Gen AI as
a cultural technology, which I really
like. It really uh lands at least in how
I perceive the AI landscape and it
perfectly positions how we should be
approaching AI from training data to rag
implementations to the classification of
output. Cultural technologies in her
terms provides ways of communicating
information between groups of people.
Examples she suggests are writing,
print, libraries, internet search
engines or even language itself. She
states that asking whether an LLM is
intelligent or knows about the world is
like asking the University of
California's library is intelligent or
whether a Google search knows the answer
to your questions. It is how you use the
technology that lends intelligence. She
reminds us that previous cultural
technologies also caused concerns. She
gives the example of Socrates thoughts
about the effects of writing on the
ability to remember. I'm not sure if
many of you are familiar with this.
Socrates believed that by codifying or
recording your thoughts in writing or
publishing that humans would in fact
lose memory, which is very similar to
what we're facing today with AI and some
of the fears around those
implementations.
So like the internet, we share concern
about the potential for people using LLM
to spread disinformation and
misinformation whether intentionally or
by accident. So you know we know that
humans or we can assume best intent.
She also notes that past cultural
technologies required new norms, new
rules, laws, and institutions to make
sure that the good outweighs the e ill.
From sharing sha by shaming liars and
honoring truth tellers to inventing
factcheckers, librarians, liel laws, and
privacy regulations.
Why are knowledge graphs at the center
of Gartner's impact raider for
generative AI?
because they are the critical helper
function for the LLM. A knowledge graph
represents the distilled organizational
business and do domain specific
knowledge of your company providing high
quality curated and structured
information to the LLM via
implementations like RAG.
that that's often the missing piece
which can change the output of the LLM
from a dangerous hallucination to a
helpful situation and a helpful solution
for business problems.
All cultural technologies if we consider
AI to be cultural technology relies upon
knowledge management.
What are examples of cultural
technologies? We see them and we live
them everywhere. So their libraries,
archives, museums, scholarly publication
channels, academia, and even search
engines such as Google and Microsoft
Bing. A knowledge graph is a tool for
knowledge management and therefore an
essential cultural practice focused upon
leveraging machines to support
information retrieval.
The ethos of knowledge management is
founded upon principles such as
accuracy truthfulness machine
readability, and interpret
interoperability with minimal bias. As a
cultural technology, the information we
model, consume, and share should
represent facts which manifest as real
ideas and real things in the real world,
all with accurate context.
One thing that cannot be automated is
deciding what the truth is. Humans must
design for the truth.
It is people that ultimately shape data
to become information. Relegating the
creation of knowledge graphs to the LLM
is like relegating the creation of eval
to the LLM without human insight.
Knowledge management as a cultural
practice is about grounding data with
facts to create information
informationrich landscapes built for
reliable information retrieval. In other
words, AI cannot exist without people.
People curating and structuring data to
become information which is then
presented as knowledge in a knowledge
graph. This fact setting establishes
ground truths to serve as LLM contextual
inputs throughout the life cycle of an
LLM. Knowledge management is the human
touch that legitimizes AI as a
trustworthy cultural technology.
So some of you may be familiar with this
type of construct and of course I use
Tim Verers Lee as the example here but
um you know for over three centuries
librarians have been managing knowledge
and evolving knowledge management
practices
with the digitization of bibliographic
records I mean that's how we found find
books or resources um in the 1960s and
the emergence of the worldwide web in
the 80s and early 90s
Librarians adopted consistent and
standardized methods for managing and
connecting distributed big data. So,
it's a knowledge management practice.
Authority records became critical to
building and connecting rich semantic
knowledge management systems. Link data
proved essential for entity resolution,
identity management, embedded
references, and citations.
This unlocked the linked the linking of
data points and records across vast
globally connected data systems and
linked data fit neatly into metadata
rich catalog records naturally
standardized and formatted using machine
readable languages and formats such as
XML and RDF.
So these same principles were
evangelized by one founder of the
worldwide web, Tim Berners Lee, who
espoused the virtues and critical
importance of linked data in his 2006
linked data note. I don't know if many
of you have seen the linked data note,
but it sort of resonates with what's
going on today. And as a side note, I
also suggest if you haven't seen his bag
of chips talk from 2009 2010, it would
also be great just to visit that. It's
easily discoverable on the web.
So uh these principles that Tim Berners
Lee evangelized uh were he espoused the
virtues and critical importance of link
data and
the interesting thing was that he had
five and it's the five star quality data
spectrum um which was HTTP
URI identifiers
um and really evangelized that HTTP URI
identifiers could help tremendously with
information retrieval, retrieval,
retrieving factual information and that
um RDF was necessary to structure data
as statements for semantic uh structured
data retrieval, sparkle for querying it
and the systematic linking of documents
across the web. If you hear today about
web 3.0 0 or the semantic web. This is
really not a new concept but a con
continuation of the founding principles
of the web. In the age of AI, everyone
using these technologies will benefit
from the first principles of authority
records, link data, and library sciences
as a practical method to minimize LLM
hallucinations. And this is not a reach.
So, this is a really interesting project
and I really encourage all of you to um
actually look or or research this
project. You know, OLC, I'm not sure how
many of you are familiar with OLC, but
it's the online computer library center.
It used to be the Ohio um li computer
library center because it's located in
Ohio or Dublin, Ohio, which is the same
town where Dublin Core comes from. So
that's a little rare Midwest hotbed for
a lot of semantic activity. Um but uh so
they are the owner and manager of
WorldCat and that's the worldwide
catalog. It is incredible. It's a
massiveworked knowledge graph that
connects um data through a very
interesting linked data system and it's
the world's largest interoperable
library catalog and it represents um you
know it it it includes uh
cooperativelyworked
environments with major knowledge graphs
such as wiki data, Amazon books, Google
books and academic scholarly
publications. uh it's a massive worked
knowledge management system and has been
the vehicle and orchestrator of
continued link data initiatives
throughout digital rep repositories of
knowledge. So beginning in 2009 each of
OLC's collaborative efforts have focused
upon launching large interoperable link
data semantic systems and it culminated
in the shared entity management
infrastructure in 2021.
So as data and information and knowledge
expands and contracts with the speed of
its creation and deletion which is
something we're all dealing with in the
knowledge graph space um linked data
provides this flexibility without
compromising the integrity of knowledge
management systems. The entire shared
link data infrastructure benefits all
users and systems through collaboration
and has established a global system for
distributed entity and identity
management. It is really impressive.
It's not perfect, but it's impressive.
Evolving library data into lip data
frees the knowledge in library
collections and connects it to the
knowledge streams that inform our
everyday lives on the web through smart
devices and using technologies like
artificial intelligence.
So why link data?
Descriptive metadata records and
ontologies can be heavy and verbose. So
we also know that how to deal with those
sorts of issues to a degree and it makes
it difficult to manage knowledge at
scale. Link data streamlines the
description process while enabling the
serendipitous discovery of new concepts
through relationships between link data
authority records. In the case of LLMs,
linked data provides structured machine
readable descriptive data and all the
same benefits are afforded to humans.
You get enhanced discoverability,
improved interoperability and contextual
understanding.
For the decade long or over a decade
long OLC data project, link data project
to be successful, communities had to
agree to the meaning of common shared
data. While each organization or
community can have their own unique
vocabularies and metadata linked data
connects unique terminology to the
commons and resolves the varied terms
via ontology rich meta records and
authority records.
It's truly is communitydriven from that
perspective. Now that OLC's link data
project has reached maturity, libraries
are shifting away from traditional
cataloging to entity and identity
management.
Identity management is entity and
identity management. So it actually and
relationship management, excuse me. So
when we talk about identity management
in the library and information science
space, it really encompasses all of
those practices with the benefit of
worked link data systems managing
entities at scale to optimize knowledge
discovery for humans and machines.
So I find it actually very interesting
that at this point or juncture that li
as a lot of enterprises are are
struggling with cataloges and moving
towards cataloges that in fact the
library and information science space is
evolving away from those traditional
methods.
One of the most valuable learnings from
the OLC linked data project is the
codification of iterative data
preparation and cleaning processes.
Without data quality and knowledge
management, linked data systems will
suffer or fail. This is at the heart of
intentional arrangement.
Thoughtful approaches to organizing
focused upon every step throughout the
process to optimize both the input and
the output. The intentional arrangement
approach creates space to focus on tasks
such as curation, entity resolution, and
data modeling. Often the demands for
speed and development cycles bypasses
critical pre and post-processing phases
resulting in diminishing returns. This
approach has been carried over into the
data preparation process for AI systems
with the OLC project. They actually and
with the OLC project they were
successfully implementing robust AI
systems between 2009 to 2019 and seeing
amazing returns from those that those
efforts
to understand link data at scale you can
visit wiki data and what's really nice
is you can use or or reach a QR code and
even um be able to land on the same page
we're looking at here as you can see
here with link data data. Each concept
is assigned an HTTP identifier that
provides its canonical definition, often
doing so with links to other authority
records and not necessarily constrained
to the wiki data environment. As you can
see on the left or sorry, the right
rail, modern LLM can directly leverage
these URIs, which is very useful for rag
implementations. It's a very neat and
tidy little package with a lot of
information.
Unfortunately, you can't see my
animation. The bike is animated because
I locked this down in a PDF. But the
idea is that, you know, link data
enables concept discovery by forging
connections between what is explicitly
modeled by humans. LLMs can leverage
link data via rag to enable the
discovery of new concepts and
relationships. And that's really
important. Link data acts as a reference
librarian for concepts defined and
managed in the worldwide web.
This is a link data ecosystem snapshot
just to show how everything is connected
and as you can see you have Google
books, OLC, Amazon books, Goodreads and
Wiki data. It's all connects through
OLC.
The thing is curation is key. Curated
link data means choosing HTTP URI
identifiers to link data ontologically
using well-designed or openly available
ontologies to support intentional data
modeling practices for knowledge
management systems.
Remember a link data ecosystem such as
the OLC linked data project consists of
knowledge graphs. That's something very
important to remember to be successful.
Aligning to a common core understanding
of entity and identity management is
key.
Let's look at the players in this
massive link data system. And this is
you have to understand there's more than
400 participants in this more than
decade long project.
We have traffic partners. So they're
organized into verticals. So traffic
partners and traffic partners span the
divide between libraries and the
worldwide web. You know they're
responsible for socializing linked data
objects to make them widely discoverable
for all consumers.
Publishing contributes to the greater
whole with scholarly publications and
research objects. You can think of
Google Scholars as like scholar is one
of the most widely recognized and
libraries represent curated uh knowledge
repositories. education and academia
represents modern uh models skills and
learning frameworks. So it's really
important because that touches how
people consume information and their
thirst for knowledge. Um it goes without
saying this project would not have been
possible without standards and funding.
That's the key key building block. So
Wiki data has emerged as the most common
universally visible product uh to emerge
from this widescale effort. Wiki data
taxonomies and ontologies are commonly
used to create knowledge graphs for rag
implementations as the barrier of entry
is very very low and you can download
readily download um any of their machine
readable formats and implement a pretty
nice okay okay knowledge graph. Many
fans do not realize that what makes wiki
data so robust and valuable is linked
data. That's in fact the underlying
principle of that entire system.
Speaking of rag, isn't it interesting
that rag and link data offer similar
benefits and returns? So I started
looking at the parallels before trying
it myself between link data and ragg. So
the benefits and returns being similar
mostly because rag relies upon quality
data connections and linked data's
entire job is to ensure the quality of
data connections.
Linked data requires that connections
are well- definfined and machine
readable and rag appreciates semantic
structure. In fact, linked data works
incredibly well with with rag
implementations because link data is
built for retrieval precision.
A link data approach streamlines
knowledge representation with a simple
HTTP URI identifier to enrich an LLM
with real world contextual
understanding.
So now we're going to get into the
really fun stuff. So um there's a new
emerging alternative to rag and I'm not
sure if many of you have heard about it.
It's called rag or retrieval interleved
generation.
Google published a paper September 2024
uh introducing rig alongside a new
offering product offering of course
called data Gemma. Data Gemma combines
Gemma and Google's link data repository
data commons similar to the OLC project
very similar uh but
it's it's a little bit different in in
its construct and its purpose uh rig
allows for multiple retrievals at
various stages of response generation
addressing all aspects of a complex
query these dynamic this dynamic
approach enables AI systems to recognize
knowledge gaps as a general generates a
response and fetches data from external
sources. That's the key, external
sources multiple times during the
process.
By continuously retrieving and
integrating information, rig reduces the
likelihood of inaccuracies in the final
output.
It is the reflection from the outside
world, external sources via link data
where rig shines.
Okay. So now this is data commons. I
don't know how many of you are familiar
with it, but uh Google's data commons is
a knowledge graph. They've been working
on it. It's open source. It's open to
the public. You can find it online. It's
a link data repository that organizes
the world's public data sets and makes
them universally accessible and useful.
The thing about data commons that's
interesting is it's mostly statistical
data. It's like census uh data, you
know, uh demographic data and and it's
mostly from public sources such as the
UN, national census bureaus, health
ministries, environmental agencies,
economic departments, NOS's. Um but it's
statistical data and that's something
that numbers is difficult for for LLMs
to deal with. But supported with linked
data, it somehow works.
Google's RIG paper
focuses on three main hypotheses,
all of which were realized and proven
true. We can see the parallels between
the benefits of rig for AI systems and
the value proposition of linked data. So
number one, external sourc sources
versus closed internal sources are
valuable for teaching LLMs when and what
to ask. Leak data is an elegant solution
for reaching into the external world of
knowledge for knowledge modeling to
support contextual understanding.
Two,
rig handles the complexity and weight of
vast amounts of data using linked data.
Linked data delivers large amounts of
contextual semantic data packaged in a
neat HTTP URI identifier.
Three, rig evangelizes the value of a
common point of entry to external data
sources via a universal API.
Link data provides a persistent
identifier linked to a common data layer
to streamline knowledge management and
sharing. We've already witnessed rig at
work whether we know it or not uh with
LLM retrievalss providing citations in
addition to citations to related
objects. RIG demonstrates a meaningful
shift towards intentional knowledge
management practices and the application
of link data like two halves of a whole.
Link data grounds humans and machines in
reality where all participants are
accountable to a common core.
Linked data architectures represent
intentional arrangements. There's so
many applications where our systems can
benefit, knowledge management systems
can benefit from linked data. In the age
of AI, building upon linked data as a
methodology for knowledge management
means a return to the first principles
established by the library sciences and
the worldwide web. The more
organizations in the data industry
reflect upon information and knowledge
management practices,
the more gaps in design decisions become
clear. Knowledge management is a
practice built upon thousands of years
of organizing resources.
If it weren't for well ststructured
linked data from OLC's project, Google
commons, wiki data, and dbpedia, LLMs
would not be as powerful as they are
today because linked data describes
resources. Use linked data. Experiment
with knowledge expansion, entity
resolution, and data preparation
workflows. I promise you'll be
surprised.
Try rag with ontologies and HTTP URI
identifiers linking concepts to the
outside world to define and ground
truth. So by prioritizing resource
description and resource description
workflows and we all know what RDF
stands for, we focus on building towards
a common core of knowledge to enrich
knowledge repositories for communities
of practice. Intentional arrangement is
about being invested in people who are
ultimately the beneficiaries and
curators of information and knowledge
retrieval.
Thanks. Do you have any questions?
We've got the mic. We can run here.
I've got one quick question to run. Um,
a discussion some of us were having at
lunch. There's been a lot of uh how how
we sh how shall we say turmoil in
enterprise orgs I've run across because
they have content management, they have
data management. They're trying to align
it now. Um,
>> would it be fair to say that li library
science has has crossed this chasm many
many
>> so many times?
>> Yeah. So many times I mean knowledge
management is a discipline and a
practice. So it's something and it's a
people process as well and I think
that's the missing piece. So the idea of
having common core or aligning with a
common core as I detailed with link data
the same thing can be true within an
organization. You can build a common
core within your own organization and
that's how libraries manage knowledge
descriptive records as well and that's
simply semantics. So that's what's
interesting. I think we over complicate
semantics. It's more than just letters
and words. Um, but it's descriptions.
It's caring about your resources.
>> Very good.
>> Yeah.
>> Other questions?
>> If not, I know we've got a lot of people
coming in right now for next session.
Um oh
>> can you
>> I wonder if you could elaborate just a
little bit on that little tidbit at the
end about the the ancient heritage, this
thousands of year old heritage.
>> Yes.
>> And how does it compare with other
heritages that are looking at this?
>> Interesting.
>> Yeah. I mean, like if we look at
cultural repositories and how they've
been curated and organized. Yeah. I
think 3rd century BC was the first
official library. Um and so I think
there has been a convergence of of
different practices and knowledge
management um because there's oral
traditions. I mean I don't want to get
too nerdy on this but if we look yeah
but we're here. Um so the knowledge
management space is is really about
integrating these different cultural
practices. Um, and I do believe that
like especially from the library science
space, they're very quick to adapt and
find ways to integrate other practices.
And that's where I think it's it's it's
a really exciting time. Believe it or
not, in the library and information
science space, they're starting to
bolster some of their data engineering
and data science practices and having
to. So from a cultural perspective it's
like this sort of if I can take or
borrow from rig you know the
presentation the idea of interle that's
truly what it takes to make you know I I
think to make a working system knowledge
management system.
>> Yeah
>> thank you very much Jessica.
>> Yeah thanks.